is the Second Amendment just for muskets
you might be asking yourself if you're
an idiot we've heard the argument
countless times from gun control
advocates so that we could have muskets
when the British people come over in
1800 you say have those guns whoo you
know back in the day when you needed to
go hunt and everything like that you
don't need those dogs daddy again the
argument here is that the Second
Amendment exists so Americans can
overthrow the government that is a view
it is it is a radical view well this is
what they had in mind when they wrote
the Second Amendment a single-shot
firearm that takes a bit of work to
reload the problem is that they're dead
wrong it's now back we'll get to all the
pre Constitution assault weapons that
already existed in a second but firstly
to accept this premise you would have to
believe that the founding fathers were
so stupid they had never ever ever
witnessed nor anticipated any kind of
technological advancement in weaponry
whatsoever the right to keep and bear
Arms shall not be infringed because get
like way bigger than today well I hadn't
thought about that believe it or not
weapons have evolved since the beginning
of mankind rocks became sharper rocks
sharper rocks became clubs clubs became
swords swords became guns accessories
also quick irony alert many of the
filthy hipsters trying to take away your
second Amendment rights are doing so by
exercising their First Amendment right
written long before their iPhones fend
but finally the good stuff the gun turns
out by the time the Second Amendment was
written many assault weapons already
existed take the belt and flintlocks for
instance which was created during the
Revolutionary War and can fire 20 or so
rounds in the pull of one trigger in
about five seconds or the jiren donee
air rifle where a 22 high-capacity round
magazine could be fired in about 30
seconds again this was created during
the Revolutionary War and was actually
later used by Thomas Jefferson to
famously outfit the Lewis and Clark
expedition
no Lewis and Clark now Shannon there's
your musket cleaned now you clean mine
we're even the Puckle gun an early
Gatling gun that was developed over 60
years before the Revolutionary War heck
even the pepperbox revolvers could hold
over 20 rounds and were developed
hundreds of years before the
Constitution by the way not only were
the founding fathers aware of these guns
they were fans for crying out loud and
the Second Amendment didn't just apply
to guns but full-on artillery here's a
letter of marque and reprisal signed by
President Madison for a privately owned
ship carrying cannons that was
authorized to attack enemy shipping
these were not muskets and the founding
fathers didn't give no craps
they were the action heroes of their day
go ahead make my day
hasta la vista baby time to party party
important takeaway here is contrary to
popular opinion even though the Second
Amendment was written to literally
include all weapons the more you dive
into it and understand its historical
context the more you see that the
founding fathers expressly wrote it to
include technologically advanced
effective weaponry so anytime a silly
leftist tries to feed you the argument
of how the Second Amendment was their
baskets send them this video because
it's done it's over now end of debate
stop trying to misinform America you
filthy hippies
if you like this video subscribe or
watch my previous installment on the
Second Amendment
if you do these things I won't shoot you
if you like this video subscribe this
video